start by fast traveling to the tower
tunnel flu flame located at the most
Southeastern point of maren weam Lake
from there start making your way back
down the mountain until you spot an area
blocked by the devil's snare routs cast
lumos and make her way through to find
our second victim as well as a couple of
chickens and two empty cages nearby this
letter is from the ministry of magic and
is giving the individual advanced notice
they'll soon be inspecting his chicken
coup for any toads on the premisis you
see in the World of Harry Potter one of
the most fearsome creatures in all of
The Wizarding World would have to be the
Basilisk breeding them would actually
land you a lifelong sentence in as
command if you stop by the daily profit
stand in Hogs me you may come across the
story about a Cornish wizard who was
arrested for breeding basilisks he
pleaded ignorance and claimed that his
Chicken cops were Simply Irresistible to
toads and while I don't think it's the
same wizard mentioned in this profit
article you actually can find the body
of an illegal breeder and one that the
ministry certainly had on their radar